Okay, so let's look at what happens,
I call this Logical Address process.
So we always talk about
physical addresses,
those are addresses that point
to locations in physical memory.
Locations in address space
are logical its a logical or
virtual address because it's going to
map to, okay so this mapping that we're
talking about here, it's going to map
to some physical memory location.
Eventually everything has to
be stored in physical memory.
So we can say logical address 2000
in process one's address space
is currently lives in physical
location 5000 or something like that.
So process the address space
that we're talking about and
the addresses that make up that address
space, zero through I said two to the n
minus one, n is 32 or 64,
these are called logical addresses.
This is in these logical addresses, or
the logical space that we define for
a process.
The process is going to put it's code,
and it's going to put it's data.
So, when we talk about an address
space as a unit of isolation, so
that if you start with this
process had its own container
of memory where it can address different
parts of it in particular different
locations where it's going to
place its code and data, and
these are logical, or in case of
virtual memory, virtual addresses.
Eventually, remember the operating
system has to use physical resources
to implement these abstractions or
virtual resources.
Well address space is a virtual
resource that abstracts memory.
So this address space or
whatever that we have here,
the information that we stored in
this address space, eventually
we have to use physical memory,
okay, that's RAM or physical memory,
to actually implement this
abstraction we call an address space.
So you enter the logical address,
you say I want to access
logical location 2000.
We have to say well that currently
lives somewhere in this physical memory
we have here.
So this code and data eventually has
to be placed in different places in
the memory that we have.
This address space has to be backed up,
physically has to be supported with
the physical memory that we have.
And this physical memory could be
multiple processes having their address
spaces concurrently being or existing
in this physical memory that we have.
So one of the things,
isolation we're talking about is that
if I'm giving up some physical memory
for address space to do process A, and
I give some physical memory
to another process B,
it then uses that memory to store some
of its stuff from its address space.
I have to isolate
the two address spaces,
I actually have to isolate both
physical memory can process
A access versus what physical
memory can process B access.
So the operating system has to do that.
I think isolation, the way to think
about this is when process A is running,
it's adding space is in some
parts of this physical memory,
it should only be able
to go to those parts.
When process B is running, it should
be able to go to only those parts that
are currently allocated to it.
And they never run into each other
unless they choose to share,
which is always sort of an exception.
So when you talk about isolation,
think of an address space
that's what a process thinks it has,
implementing that address space by
storing pieces of pieces of indifferent
parts of memory, and then making sure
that the process can only go to
physical memory that belongs to it.
And that's how we get this isolation.
So one of the things we want to do
is how exactly does it work, so
to get some sense of that.